[Musique]
bonjour gabla pour les ministres dans
genre voilà le moule appel car j'ai
perdu ma femme dans un accident de
voiture est liée à pau une attente très
bien car en ce moment l'état propose des
aides pour l'achat d'un véhicule neuf
[Musique]
et quelle importance ma situation
personnelle mais enfin je suis un haut
fonctionnaire
je suis révocable and not sommes tous
les mercredis c'est quoi votre problème
et en grand honneur que je vous demande
d'accueillir mon ami hubert félix
thiéfaine
[Applaudissements]
nous avons par la taille
[Musique]
j'ai volé
un truc l'oméga les cartons j'ai volé
mon âme
je répondrais baby foot géant
à
[Musique]